this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome to this week's seminar on people
computers in design I'm Michael
Bernstein faculty here in computer
science and human computer interaction
this week we are really excited to host
panel sepia Otis who's a faculty member
in the stern school of business over at
NYU and I think if there's a single
person who has really helped catalyze
crowdsourcing as an academic field and
effort it would be this individual who
really early on actually through a blog
presence originally called behind enemy
lines then got backed off to a computer
scientist in a business school was
really talking publicly and early about
what it means to have crowd-sourced
labor how to do it accurately and how to
do it well and I think that a lot of
what we have today as an academic
endeavor trying to understand how people
connecting and contribute online is has
been catalyzed by panos so at this point
I'll hand it over to him thanks Michael
for giving me credit that they don't
deserve but it's a pleasure to be here
so what I'm going to talk today is some
of the experiences that I have in
building systems that are using
crowdsourcing and with using humans that
are imperfect and they make mistakes and
so in order to build something good
automated machine learning system so the
broad goal oh what I'm trying to do
is try to find ways to integrate human
intelligence that you can access over
the Internet today with machines and try
to create some a hybrid system that
operates better than either of the two
good so I will focus most of the
description of the talk to the around a
concrete task that has to do with online
advertising can online advertising
application but most of the lessons are
can be easily generalized the variety of
different settings so what this lot is
sewing is two things one is how much
time people spend across the
mediums across TV reading newspapers
listening to the radio browsing the
internet and so on this is the black bar
and the red bar is what fraction of the
marketing budget gets allocated across
these different mediums so you can see
for example that thirty-seven percent of
the time people watch TV and thirty-two
percent of the marketing budget gets
allocated there however if you look at
the internet you will see that people
spend a lot of time today browsing the
internet but marketing budgets haven't
shifted into the internet yet the
opposite happens for newspapers say yes
yes so you can see well does this thing
happen and the basic explanation is the
following marketing has this big
division so you are familiar with
internet advertising the ads that you
see on google you search you see not you
click and so on this type of ads they
were traditionally associated with
people in marketing firms that were
doing direct marketing telemarketers
people that were sending cut mail at
home and so on these people who are
evaluated based on the responses that
they were getting so conceptually it was
very easy to transition on the internet
measure your performance pay per click
acquisition and so on however if you are
a marketer the prestigious job there is
not to do direct market these are the
guys that are in the basement of the
marketing firms the prestigious job is
to do brand advertising what's branded
vertising well coca-cola doesn't care
when they show you an odd whether you
are click then we are going to go to the
site or whether you are going to buy
call a call on line Delta doesn't care
if you are going to click on the app
directly to buy an airline ticket what
they want is you to see the brand often
and remember about it and these guys are
very afraid of improv
ad placement placing the ad in a place
that is not appropriate for the brand so
here's an example of this inappropriate
transfer here here is x
discussing the shootings of a
congresswoman gabrielle gibbons our last
january the article talks about the
shootings about the events and so on and
that network analyzing the content of
the article delivers this ad here the
relevance algorithm that examined God's
the relevance of this ad with a content
did a tremendously good job and the
placement is completely inappropriate as
well ah other brands have I guess they
both the publisher doesn't want that and
sometimes even they ran so other brands
have similar issues for example Affleck
here area like this one so few years
back people came and said well what we
want to do is we want to build
classifiers that detect different types
of content that different brands don't
want to be associated with and I look at
I say okay though so you want to build a
web classifier big deal that was what
people were doing back in 1995 but then
I realize that the task was not as easy
so the demand to build the model had a
very quick turnaround time so for
example they had the pharmaceutical firm
comes and says we have the following
problem we market the drug that
apparently many doctors are using in an
off-label manner to treat wine flew off
label means that it hasn't been approved
by the FDA to for this purpose but
doctors are prescribing in any case of
course the pharmaceutical firm didn't
mark in mind are prescribing an
extremely expensive drugs to patients
the FDA realizes that and say you know
what we understand what you are doing
that you are implicitly approving this
practice so what is to do is you sat
down any ad that appears in content that
disguise swine flu so the pharmaceutical
firm had two options a sat down
completely their advertising campaign
you know many million dollars per week
or try to figure out which pages contain
swine flu discussion and not appear
against this content other firms have
similar my concerns are big fast food
chain didn't want to appear next to any
page that discusses cholesterol obesity
and all the nice things that you get
from fast food airline company didn't
want to appear next to discussions of
terrorist terrorist plots accidents and
so on and for that we have typically
just a few days to build the model now
traditionally if you want to build such
a machine learning model you spend a lot
of time starting the domain collecting
data training your models and so on
today we didn't in this setting we don't
have this opportunity we have just a few
days however what we can do today is we
can say well in order to collect the
data to build our model instead of
having local people we can go online
hire people through mechanical turk
through our desk and through other such
online labor firms get them to do the
work and have a very quick turnaround
there are two problems one is that
quality might not be good but on the
other hand the cost benefits allow us to
do better worker so just for those of
you that might not have heard about
Amazon Mechanical Turk Amazon Mechanical
Turk is a marketplace where people post
micro tasks and they pay micro payments
for the completion of this task so for
example here we have
sunbirds who is asking people to
identify Arabic dialect in the text he
has 14 thousand such documents and he's
paying five cents per document so here's
how the task look like looks like so
people see the text here they're in
Arabic and people know Arabic they know
typically the dialect from which these
texts come so for example the manor
dialects are the Moroccan and Algerian
dialect Egyptian saudi arabia saudi
arabia velbon lebanon syria and tie
Rakhi if you know Arabic this is a very
quick task so you look at the sentencing
you say this Arabic this is Saudi the
Saudi this is Lebanese and so on and get
paid five cents so for our purposes we
said we are going to do the same to
collect data about the true click types
of offensive content that appear on a
web page so here's a very simple example
most but the Tigers don't want to appear
in adult next adult content where adult
content can be as Extreme as hardcore
porn or you know any discussion about
you know celebrities and you know what
they are doing in the private life and
so on so what we want to do was to have
four categories for adult content
general audience natick invasive pg-13
it is content that children below 13
should have should not be exposed to our
means that you should be an adult to be
exposed to an axis hardcore porn when we
have local people to do the task people
could do
200 websites per hour approximately 20
seconds per website and they will get in
paid fifteen dollars per hour then we
post on Mechanical Turk and since many
people could operate on the task at the
same time and label its web page we will
run up to 2500 websites that our aunt
actually our aggregate cost was even
lower so we look at that say well that's
real good 10 times a Productivity lower
cost we're golden and till we actually
start to look at what we are actually
getting so we put for example this guy
with ID ati mr 044 tabla he looks at the
website all vintage poor classification
general audience hot XXX asia
classification general areas the fact we
have guided doesn't even pay attention
to the URL that he is classifying just
press this jejejejejejeje and he hopes
once he is done we're going to pay him
in since the problem yes we could check
what people are sending back and kick
out the bad guys the problem is that for
this type of tasks it doesn't make sense
to verify the work if i'm going to look
at its web page and decide whether the
person gave the correct answer i might
as well do the work myself so it's
costly to verify second since i'm hiring
people online i have no idea how good
they are they might be Titus come past
they might be good but I need to know
how what are the correct answers for
whatever i'm trying to do neither i know
how good are the people so and i want to
figure out what are the correct answers
and potentially want to know how good
are the people so we'll say how can we
solve that so the first idea is the
redundancy can be our friend so instead
of asking one person to do a task we can
ask multiple people so for example
here's our guy Miss Palmer in a
redundancy setting so for example we
have the site 25 you calm ten people
label it everyone says g10 audience
that's a good indication of this chain
rodents we look now at the 30 plus 40
plus everyone else's this is a porn site
our guy hears sticks out says general
audience that gives us an indication
that something is wrong with a cancer
and if we take this idea and you try to
generalize it it gives birth to an
algorithm that we initially thought that
it was novel then we realize that this
algorithm has been invented back in
nineteen seventy nine for the setting
where they had doctors new doctors
resident doctors that were trying to
figure out how good they are in
diagnosing patients of course you cannot
have a senior doctor doing the diagnosis
and then the residents are following him
form of a test that was very costly so
therefore they had resident doctors
diagnose patients and based on that
without of course knowing the diagnosis
for the basin and then they were trying
to figure out how good are the doctors
and go to the correct diagnosis for the
patient and here's how the algorithm
works you say okay let's get the
assessments of what people said then
let's say that the majority vote is
correct then once we
the correct answer will say the majority
we say let's now see how often each of
the workers agrees with the majority and
based on that we estimate what we call
the confusion matrix so for example how
often does the guy look at something for
which the majority says gee and
classifies as chief Ross Palmer here
because ninety nine percent of the time
that was good however our spammer
whenever he was looking at something
where the majority was saying poor also
ninety-nine percent of the time he was
saying let's G so effectively the guy
was just saying t all the time and then
you can continue this algorithm
territory you can rest Amit next what's
the correct answer but now instead of
considering each person to be equal you
say I am going to wait down the answers
that come from but guys like this and
I'm going to rank higher the answers
that come from high quality guys and you
do again kind of a weighted majority
voting and this thing converges and you
get back this type of estimates for the
workers now we look at that and said ok
we're done we know how good they're the
guys because we can see how often they
are incorrect right everything outside
the diagonal is incorrect unfortunately
that was not the case here's the problem
the spammer he was lazy but he was not
stupid he said you know
to get paid I need to minimize the
errors but I'm drink but to the other
hand I don't want to be an obviously bad
guy what he realizes that in the
majority of the things that he had to do
there was no adult content therefore he
looks at that session if I say always
gee I'm going just occasionally to have
an error since nine or eight out of ten
of the URLs don't have anything I can
just say everything is good everything
is good and I will have an occasional
error indeed actually his error rate was
fifteen percent because he was
classifying everything into general
audience and most of the sides are
indeed general audience the other guy
that also makes mistakes but in both
directions right he looks at the porn
website thinkin misclassified as good
but also like you know the other way has
much higher rate so we can see that our
spammer despite the fact that it does no
work actually has lower rate and a guy
that pays attention but his erroneous
look that's a gay let's not worry about
this part doesn't seem that important
we'll get back to that will find the
worst guys first with the highest error
rate we'll kick them out and then we'll
get back to this case then we rank the
guys to see who are the worst offenders
the worst offender was the CEO of the
company that was doing this task
followed by all the internal employees
look at that say k we have a bug let's
fix it unfortunately there was no back
here is how the CEO of the company with
labeling things so two characteristics
she was a woman with a young family at
few young kids home this is the CEO of a
company that tries to detect offensive
content to the internet right so there
is an obvious bias to detect offensive
content where there is none so here's
how she was labeling things
whenever she was looking at something
that the worst general audience only
twenty percent of the times you were
saying this general audience eighty
percent of the times you're saying all
this is pg-13 my kids should not be
exposed to this content this is not
content for kids whenever she was
looking at content that was actually
pg-13 so you're saying this is art this
is adult only and whenever she was
looking at our content she was also
classifying time and same thing for pork
and of course this was generating
tremendously high error rates had a
seventy-three percent error rate she was
seventy-three percent of the time she
was disagreeing with the commonly
accepted answer however if you look at
here mistakes they are actually
extremely predictable so for example
when says gee we know it's three
whenever says pg-13 it's never busy 30
it's always G so yes is this mistaken
but we can always fix that when she says
are we have a little bit of ambiguity
but when says poor we know thats is good
if you compare that to the spammer we
have a big difference here whenever the
spammer says you have no idea what this
thing is it can be anything it can be G
it can be pg-13 so there is no real
information that we get from the spam so
for that we said okay we are going to do
the following first we are going to fix
all the errors of the biases that we can
and then see what is the leftover error
so for example for the spammer when he
says gee our best guess for the answer
is something like it can be twenty-five
percent G 25 pins percent pg-13
twenty-five percent are and so on so so
you have to pick one of these categories
we have a 75-percent expected error for
the good word
who says this is a team well we know
that it's always G there is not be good
here so we note is G so the expected
error rate there is actually 0 now based
on that we could create a quality score
that now consolidates this type of fans
have seen to a metric that we call
quality which says which is equal to 1
minus the expected cost of the work f
divided by the cost of this panel if
your decisions generate the same cost as
a spammer your quality 0 if your cost of
your decisions is 0 your qualities one
can't represent now this metric has two
good characteristics a it removes any
bias so we fix the bias and then we
evaluate you and second its color metric
which means that we can rank people for
a matrix you cannot do them yes
contradictory to the first were you
introduced it to someone who pick the
same category regardless and so you have
very different entropy on those two
things so curious why the switch here
what do you need what this your first
case the spammer clicked gene for every
day and now you're saying spammers one
who signs labels randomly so you went
from low to high entry protocol but I'm
going to actually if I would say there
are movies they don't work ok without
giving us any information so even if you
do randomly or if you always press C or
a lot with press X your cost is always
going to be the same because your
confusion matrix effectively will say I
cannot separate whenever you say
something G or PG 13 or app or anything
I I cannot infer anything meaningful
about your answers all your answers are
going to regenerate into this so if you
give completely random answers again the
correct answer will be this twenty-five
percent for everything
if curious so for example if I gave Jeff
restaurant advice and I always undersold
it he would know exactly what to in
first even though it isn't what I said
what actually can think about that in my
confidence abuse I think if someone says
strong reject for everything and his
weekly tech is equivalent to an accept
of someone else you have a very
systematic bias that you can figure out
if someone says except for only the best
paper and everything else gets week
except then if the week except is not a
week except right it is equivalent to
the strong critic of the other person
this is you biasing and then the random
answer Connecticut actually so that even
machine learning they say that there are
you don't have a boat ride so he can for
something we throw that right it can be
extremely accurate but you can click
completely off center in that case you
are good you just need to calibrate your
throwing yeah in that case you will be
like this good worker right low entropy
but biased so you are completely off but
if you fix your answers or if I fix if I
move the target right you're perfect in
that case we are moving the target
ourselves we don't let them know about
anything but if you are throwing all
over the place I cannot do anything with
that okay so to find the body of a
person you really need to know where the
two answers are and you to answer so
dependent on consensus if you have more
standards that you have you are a playa
did you actually have all Spanish and
they are not connected they will filter
out themselves because they will never
agree with each other but you want the
answer in no no no no if I however
tremendous amount of noise but it is not
correlated with each other the good guys
will get out and we'll give me a signal
about the
answer if I say if I have eight spammers
in two good guys and they'd spammers are
not coordinated or correlate with each
other they will not have any effect on
the consensus vote unless most day well
in that case if they are coordinated
girl grant they will dominate position
well curve but quickly if you announce
pamela cell values the two answers sorry
if you're not stammers the biased then
you still do another two answers hi you
have systemic bias figure out then you
are going to get a biased consensus yeah
in that case if you introduce a few
control points as gold tests as then you
can find out the tires of the crowd
actually have this thing for example
when this thing was running in India
where we serve us as people call it they
were pitchy friendly they they were
always pushing things as PT and above
because they felt that this was that
duty to classify things as pity in the
example here it is it's like is just to
a uniform fire for what does auto levels
could be yay what does the test get less
powerful is you know really all of them
are mostly G with them is only a few
each is the same thing I just pushing
education I should quit perfect
what does this test it less power voice
you do need more data to difference in
general this is all pointing to it a
problem that we can't distinguish
legitimate agreements from illicit
coordination right this is why porsha
and legs together as the time's person
of the year I'm trying to get the
interrogations endorsing their problem
very such study this problem in the
theory of distributed systems about be
some time algorithms and how they can
take over the network and so on so I'm
trying to figure out in this setting
what are they appropriate what are the
but we have first of how many spammers
coordinate can take over the network and
be how we can secure against that so I I
don't have an answer but I think it's a
promising I have wondered because you
can introduce some Mel small a small set
of gold standard if actually you know
it's not anywhere nearly as pessimistic
because then I think let's distributed
system in Billy yes I would like to have
some who's we say okay if you add ten
percent gold tests the probability that
spammers can take over your network
drops to a percent but I don't have such
things at this point so the next thing
that we want to see okay we know how
good are the people what can we do that
Scott so we want it to initially we had
a very naive approach where we have this
stress holding so we're saying if you
are above sixty percent quality you get
paid if you drop below that we reject
your we give you warning and so on
unfortunately this strategy has a couple
of negative properties a the very good
guys they didn't feel the pressure to
give the best work they were saying okay
you know what the threshold is sixty
percent about ninety percent I I can go
faster and get more work done as opposed
to giving higher quality second when you
have a hard decision threshold the guys
that are just below that they feel very
bad just because their friend who got
51% gets the job and they got few
49-percent they get rejected which is
bad so for that we introduced this idea
of quality sensitive payment that
operates as follows so we said let's set
the price that is acceptable called
ninety percent for ninety percent you
get full payment then we said what about
the guy that is eighty percent how much
should we pay this guy so the day then
80 / 90 or what so
and for that we said okay we're going to
have equivalency so how many workers do
I need of athlete eight percent quality
to reach the ninety percent threshold I
need three guys like that therefore the
guy with eighty percent quality gets one
third of the pavement of the guy with
ninety percent gold the guy that has
seventy percent cold because i need nine
guys like that gets 111 sense and this
is a very snug this thing has a nice
property hey you don't have a hard
decision threshold but the payment drops
quite quickly as your quality drops
therefore people have the incentive to
do the best or at least to calibrate
their answers to give you the best time
adjusted call to the taker and as it
works reasonably well to encourage
people to hit high levels of quality one
of the problems that we done with that
was that our own estimates of their
quality was bad not bad but uncertain
was movin especially people that did ten
things for us we were not quite certain
about the quality or something like
ninety percent plus minus five percent
you might hit the eighty-five percent
estimate and so on and we under pay you
so for that we did we introduced the
concept of a refund so we get people
that they start working for us and we
start estimating their quality over time
assuming that they're caulk remains
certain we start for example say okay we
did 10 examples for us your current
estimated quality seventy percent you
get paid as a worker that is seven
percent accurate then even after you
have done a few more we say home you are
not a seventy percent work at your
native person worker I start getting a
better understanding of your quality so
therefore not only you are going to get
paid for this task as an eighty percent
worker i am going to give a refund for
your prior
work that captures the fact that I was
the bad guy that didn't estimate
properly your question and you get the
refund then as time goes by i estimate
your quality better and better and i
start refunding effectively whatever I
didn't tell you because I underestimated
your quality so you can see in that case
actually that scheme has a very nice
property as time goes by people because
they get the reference from ariat they
have the incentive to go on for as much
they can because they say home you know
if I work a little bit more I'm going to
get paid for the missing payment that
they owe me for the last five rounds and
if I improve my quality in the next
round I'm going to get the missing
payment for whatever I haven't been paid
in the past so eventually until they
reach that true level of our estimate
reaches the true level of quality people
keep getting refunds for the prior work
and they keep working for us actually
then some experiments that we ran we
could see that by paying people like
that they stick around for longer
because they expect you know they see
actually the verb bonded we don't tell
them at that is the refund this is we
say that this is a bonus for maintaining
performance and people stick around for
the task because they see the bonuses
that keep coming over time so if you
want I will not spend too much time for
that but ill have questions ask me
afterwards now so far I describe the
setting where I used the human
intelligence of humans very possibly I
say here's the page label it here is the
page label it but we said okay this is
very unsatisfying we treat people as
very naive machines
so instead of asking now people to
passively label page that we give them
you said can we do the following we are
going to instead of giving them pages
and asking them to classify we are going
to ask them to find these pages for us
so for example we wanted to build a
model that the dexa hate speech on the
web if you randomly sample the web and
ask people to label the pages you're
going to waste a lot of time asking
people to label page without hate speech
fortunately there is not that much hate
speech on the web and however if you go
and ask people to find content they're
actually very good at that and here's
one very nice advantage over of this
distributed crowd if I ask every single
one of you to think about hate speech
and send him back five pages that
contain hatred every person has a very
strong bias in limited thinking about
what exactly is hate speech actually we
tried it ourselves and we couldn't find
more than 100 examples it we kept
running into our own cognitive limits
however on the web you put it out and
people have completely different
experiences and therefore they send you
back completely different data for
example we had this guy that was saying
you know male chauvinist blogspot.com
right so the guy was kept going on about
women how bad they are and so on so you
have people that you know mainstream
racists you know white pride new Nazi
guys anti-semitism guys you have the run
to other things like black people racist
against white and all sorts of hate
speech that you can only grasp if you
have access to a wide
diversity of fur thinking axial that was
a pretty good case study for the crab
yes whenever I find you to say everyone
is responds with the first the top five
is also a google search for each speech
yes actually we don't allow to be take
things and people have already submitted
and leave a meeting on the domain and
normal a urls / to make mini damages cut
but you need to fix the google bias
that's right but even beyond that once
you prevent them from using the obvious
Google Curie afterwards they start
thinking of their own search strategies
for Google to find hate speech right and
starts working pretty well yes yeah
information about what they tried but
you didn't allow because it was it would
be a Jupiter is that would be one way
and do but I don't you study things for
that this feels a lot these are my
measures when you are looking for
example find me wine stores in Palo Alto
people go and they tip wine store palo
alt and you are going to get hundred
people issuing the same ten wine stores
that Google perhaps so but that it can
go one step further action so now but
even with this strategy in mind we
started running into limits after
getting a thousand URLs back people keep
something
things that we already know how to
handle yet another racism page get
another in a racist jokes and so on this
gives birth to what we call blissful
ignorance our Moodle has let say
thousands of pages that contain hate
speech and then you are trying to
evaluate your model the classifier has
this implicit assumption that the world
is closed it's all represented in the
training data so you split your training
data you do cross validation and all
these techniques that people used
evaluate cross machine learning models
everything seems great until the open
world hits and to quote Rumsfeld we have
this unknown unknowns what's in unknown
unknown it is the case where the
classifier fails to discover the content
and fails with confidence I'm absolutely
confident that there is no hate speech
on this page while this it's one of the
most horrible pages that you can find on
Waveland so for example we have this
blog that I hatreds of Santa tistic
children we didn't have anything like
that in retraining it we couldn't
believe it now in nobody thought about
that the classifier looks at that and
says oh none of the terms that is
associated with hate speech is in here
it seems perfectly legitimate and
actually I see it's about children this
page therefore get decide about the
child eight preschools right this is
what the fail campaigns are made are
being made off on the internet and plus
this thing happens trying to explain
things that the classifiers are
statistical creatures and they fail from
time to time and so on these things
don't matter you have the PR disaster
happening and claiming that this thing
happens only 0.01 percent of the time
blah blah it's it's relevant you have
lost credibility you have lost
reputation so on so that they will use
humans to find the
things proactively so for that we built
the system that we call it beat the
machine and the beat the machine works
as follows we have a black box that is a
classifier the classified gets a simple
to URL and outputs a category so we
asked people to the following go out to
the web and find the URL that the
classifier will say that it doesn't
contain any H bits for example while a
human a trusted human that looks at that
says this is a hatred so effectively
beat the machine if the incentive
structure is you get one dollar if you
submit something that causes the
classifier to fail and you get some like
0.1 cent if we are correct you get paid
something but your incentive is clearly
on the side of trying to beat the
machine so if you see you want to see
the conceptual equivalent people that
are doing for example network security
people get paid in order to break into
the system if they don't break the
system they don't get paid so similarly
we have this thing but for an automated
system we ask people to better taste the
classifier break the classifier that's
the idea you get paid when you break the
system sorry if they get paid they in
the system like I know I do I hacked it
but
you know what we keep the asset from the
customer the class 5a today so they've
just you're absolutely machine do that
as opposed to hear this video units in
the area dancer so yes even finish
school it's a go you're pulling me
you're always saying there's no cake
sitting here saying you don't pay me but
since we pay I think this is what
establishes trust that they start
getting paid when they break the system
as opposed to getting always oh my gosh
fight is good thank you so something
about these classifiers and Generals
that they make a very and they have
comments but there is some decision they
make and there are a lot of pages on the
on the web that there is subjectivity to
this and there's their gray areas no I'm
not certain that a classifier is really
going to be able to the right model to
that kind and unity well not training
was fine you need to agree it's
important that i have a region in
conceptual region in the space that i
classify as pg-13 the world might
disagree with me but as a classifier i
get trained with fixed labels right so
the classifier itself gets trained like
that so humans might disagree with a
classifier but so enter the classifier
but those don't forget that people will
going to be compared also with the
answer that the other human will give so
you have a set of trusted humans that
are playing with you on the system sir
and I so we started doing that and we
said okay let's see how good their
people in doing that end for example for
our hate speech model they submit two
thousand URLs sixteen percent of the
time they found a mistake we managed to
break the crossfire for legal drug use
about five percent for alcohol abuse
thirty percent of the time they were
managed to break the classified so James
that was answering your questions we
start getting paid from these things so
they start trusting that this is a real
system and for adult also approximately
fifteen to twenty percent these error
rate the success rate was sound like 10
200 times higher than what we're
expecting the classifier to fail in
random traffic and color we start using
the system then we realize the following
once you find them say they don't stop
there for example they figured out that
we really bad at multilingual so there's
a bit one multilingual page the
classifier looks at the texas oh no term
that they recognize therefore it belongs
to the majority class which is nothing
offensive and of course they will sign
it afterwards probing in that one so
this we started getting the japanese
porn chinese porn you know german porn
finish porn german HP it's europe and so
on at this point though these failures
were not unknown unknowns they were
known unknown i know that i SAT with i
know at the second multilingual so i
don't need anything like that anymore so
for that we actually it was not trivial
to fix the
fire on the fly to handle this court and
tax it was takes a long effort however
what we could do we could do a second
layer model that was detecting is this
probe similar to any other successful
probes that I received in the past
therefore a doctor some point will say
okay after people submit enough
multilingual staff say okay I start
recognizing that this thing with German
words tends to be a successful probe so
the when people submit something that we
predict that is going to be successful
say thank you but is the known unknown
so you are not going to get paid the
same amount as before and actually the
structure now is one dollar if you
submit us an unknown unknown we fail we
fail where we are confident that we are
correct and we don't know about that
that is one dollar the reward drops if
we say here's the probe oh but we say we
already know about that the model fails
with confidence but we already know
about this area therefore your payment
is lower and the lowest amount of
payment is when people submit URLs that
the classifier already says I don't know
what to do with that it I'm very
uncertain about the outcome it can't
contain hate speech or not so that was
the bit they were same structure because
it we started using this structure for a
variety of systems not only for the big
machine we are effectively paying people
to interact with our systems and
different algorithms to figure out ways
that we fail and we give unpredictable
and bad outcomes now final part so far I
have described cases where I evaluate
people I tell them how good they are in
terms of quality I pay them when they
are successful and so on I de sky with
decide how much to pay them and so on
the problem is that people don't like to
be evaluated
nobody likes to have a score associate
with their performance students don't
like to get midterm grades workers don't
like to be evaluated everyone wants to
feel it there create them when we don't
actually the reactions can be surprising
to use the moderator so for example one
guy in mechanical turk realize that he
score dropped she started writing me a
long email you know his score dropped
from certain like hundred percent to 90
something percent ubp peep I know what
you're trying to do you're trying to
reject my work you're trying to
artificially lower my score so that you
have an excuse not to pay me I know your
kind you requesters with your automated
systems I don't know how many times this
guy has been burned in the past so and
he was actually pretty good and then we
lose this a desk guy that had a similar
drop in his car and he started saying co
please don't fire and please don't fight
may really like my job I really like
what I'm doing tell me what I'm supposed
to do in order to improve my performance
I will do the best to give you the best
workout you want boss I will do
everything and so on again she was
pretty good so couple of years back I
was in a conference by national academy
of sciences that they called frontiers
of science the setting is that they get
people from a wide variety of
disciplines physicists biologists
economists climate change people
computer scientists they talk just
present your work something might have
so presenting this work about quality on
outsourcing and they have Don Cooper
with a biologist cognitive psychology
neurobiologist in University of Colorado
I say yes your workers behave like my
mice it's okay
go on get workers what they want to do
is they want to use their motor skills
and they don't want to use their
cognition the cognitive skills so here's
what it means the brain despite the fact
that it is a pretty small organ it's
about three pounds it consumes a
tremendous amount of energy it consumes
twenty percent of your daily engines
therefore biologically speaking the
brain tries to delegate many of the
tasks to other less energy hungry parts
of the body so for example when you're
working your brain doesn't get directly
involved it has delegate listening to
the autonomous nervous system your brain
will get involved only when you stumble
on something or if you press a garment
your leg gets stuck in something so I
look at say sir so what your workers are
trying to do is they are trying to
delegate cognition to motor skills they
just want to go click lick lick lick
lick lick lick and get paid they don't
think about it I think yeah that's a
biological tendency I say that's good
connection make sense thank you that's a
nice connection to remember not done ok
here's what I'm doing to train my mice
to behave to use their cognitive skills
and not their motor skills here the
experiment so mice the reward is food I
they like to eat so it has is to setting
now we're mice have to set two ways to
find food one is they go to a bucket
that has pellets they press a lever
repeal it drops late get happy the
rather these motor skills right just
repress food eat the other approach is
there is a maze they need to solve the
maze to find to find the food and it
this requires cognition of course if you
leave it to their own devices they might
just press the letter
they get the food they don't even get
into the maze how does how can you make
the mice to use the maze basic idea is
you confuse the motor skill and you
reward cognition what does it mean to
reward to confuse motor skills here
instead of giving the food directly when
they press the lever you make it
probabilistic sometimes you give them
food sometimes you don't so my is now
this thing stops being a mechanical
action right they drop this thing
where's my food so they get you know
what I might as well solve the maze
where I know where the food is so
extending that this idea you can try to
play the same games with humans online
so for example when I detect that the
quality of the submission is dropping
instead of telling people you are bad
you start giving them implicit fig but
by frustrating them so for example when
they are about to label image the image
is ready but we start introducing
artificial delay please wait image
loading image loading image loading much
loading and here it is so you know or
image didn't glow please come back again
or a 404 error reject the heat and come
back again and so on so and again you
should make this probabilistic if you
make it deterministic here is the wrong
answer and you get this delays people
figure out that something is wrong but
you can make it probabilistic it starts
working it you have the opposite side
where you are trying to reward cognition
cognition likes to see variety so they
like to see new things and sewing you
should not make the task boring so we
try to play with that interestingly
enough so when I was at MIT plus
here they called know there is a plug-in
for attenti here is a Drupal plugin that
is called misery that if you have a
website that has users and you have
trolls that you want to get rid of if
you block that account they will come
back they will open a new one but with
this misery you can say oh this IP
address or this account will start
getting the following treatment you know
so for example forty percent of the time
you introduce a random delay in serving
Capades or not ten percent of the time
give them a wide screen you know or a
wrong pace over a random page or a 403
error or a 404 error and of course you
make this their experience with the site
miserable so if you want to drive
someone out instead of telling them
you're burnt you cannot enter the club
you just make the club really suck for
them and this is called slow burning the
other strategy is connected to that it's
called hell bombing where you mark
people as undesirable you send them to
different rings of hell and there they
can see only other people that have the
same property so for example you might
have two trolls fighting each other you
suck you suck no you suck you suck you
suck and nobody else in the side can see
their fight so the fighting the comments
everything seems normal but they are
there you know nobody else can sing them
that's hell bunny so we started playing
with this idea of slow burning and we
tried all sorts of tasks like web page
classification tagging commodities
collect URLs and indeed we realize that
instead of God getting sixty percent
wrong you know spammy submissions so
what happens is that if you leave your
tasks codes unprotected spammers come
since they have no cost in submitting
crappy work they submit a lot of work so
typically sixty percent of the work that
you will get back will be completely
crappy it will come from a few users but
it will be crappy
and we realize that the quality of the
answers improved significantly instead
of getting hundred plus submissions from
spammers we're getting less than five
their quality they they couldn't submit
maths actually because they were getting
all these delays and we get in closer
than three percenter bad submissions the
good work is actually they were mostly
and affected so they kept working but we
notice the following that we're getting
slightly longer response times and there
was another interesting result I came
back I was discussing this result with a
biologist they said do you see
conversions hey what's the conversion
well but workers start behaving well and
everything should not happen right I
mean spam is a spammer there's no no no
no there should be some people in the
border that realized that it makes sense
for them to start doing good work and TD
that service stand by that approximately
fifteen percent of the spammers started
submitting good work which way I found
extremely surprising because I couldn't
understand why and the other very
surprising thing was that why the good
workers were unaffected they were
affected why did he start being slower I
was not treating them with delays I was
not interfering with their tasks so why
they start being so actually was
rewarding recognition we're giving them
novelty I was giving them faster
interaction so why'd they start being
slower that didn't make much sense
actually I was sitting on this thing for
quite a while because I didn't know what
to do with that until I read this book
this is a book by a Nobel Prize winner
Daniel Kahneman in the field of
behavioral economics and he's in the
intersection of psychology and economics
accessible this theory
of motor skills and the cognitive skills
can be transformed a little bit so it
says in the psychology in the brain we
have two systems we have system one that
takes care of the simple things that we
do and system two with that takes care
of the intelligent action so here's for
example system one you look at two
objects and you figure out one is that
longer further away than the other this
is a difficult task right people that do
computer vision know that very well or
figure out where from a sound is coming
or if I ask two and two how much you get
for quickly and so on these are things
that your brain does very easily and
almost automatically and has this thing
that says find the Strunk moving chess
is that not a system one think unless
you are a chess master if you are a
chess master you have internalized this
skill so much that you don't think about
it it just clay into Italy you look at
the at the board and you say well that's
a good move I don't know why but it's a
good move so it becomes system one task
for the chess masters which actually
started giving a hint what was going on
a system to tasks by the way are things
like you know focus attention on clothes
inside and a circus or find someone in
the crowd and so on so what was
happening we had people doing this
boring monotonous tasks of labeling web
pages but they were good at that they
were getting in the zone of effectively
submitting things and dealing with the
content very quickly they didn't need to
think about that it was monotonous but
they could handle monotonous work this
actually most academics fine very
unfamiliar that there are people that
like monotonous cognitive work my
assistant actually says that that cereal
likes extremely boring predictable works
it doesn't like when I bring new things
here to Delhi but
what was what we're doing by introducing
these novelty treatments and to wake
them up to give them something more
interesting we're getting them out of
that system one processing people were
processing thing is this system one with
or novelty we're pushing them to use
their system to the most slow the more
expensive but so therefore now we have a
system that says if people are fast and
they deal with monotonous work and we do
good work leave them there there in
system one processing and we are doing
well if they don't start giving them
some treatments you know delay the page
introduce some annoyance this brings
them back into system to into the
intelligent part and of course if they
keep not performing well you can slow
bank and kick them out of the system and
people that are here test give them some
boring things to do and see if they can
handle that without problems in quality
if they are system one processors they
are great don't touch them they real
good in what they are doing and this
actually gives a nice balance into the
system I will stop here and if you have
any questions I'd be happy to answer
like the mice problem with the maze and
advocating of things when you're hitting
the thing and you're getting our was
like it reminds me of the slot machine
for gambling so why do people like the
slot machine so much and what did you is
it the case that some of those lights
are that you know some people just want
to just get that thing repetitively even
with the probabilistic rewards I haven't
Lilliquist differently just an old right
I remember some results from about a
hundred years ago tell us that the BF
Skinner get on rats and he hadn't
pushing a lever and there's a whole
study we call schedules of reinforcement
his conclusion was random variable
reinforcement caused more behavior than
predictable okay now I know he's doing a
picture but this guy is doing re
different kind of rats or conditionally
different enough but least but I've
always said this is why slot machines
work if you don't have a sure it was
going to work you keep trying so in the
Skinner case the random rewards in the
modern era is email people check their
email frequently because every now and
then the spot machine pays out but most
of the time it doesn't and I think the
difference here is that so in a classic
random reward study you take a scheduled
reward one pellet for each Pole and you
bury it so the average remains one
pellet per pole but sometimes you get
five and sometimes you be zero and my
hunch would be that your best friend was
reducing the rewards level and but using
random awards to camouflage the fact
that it would be reduced so the the
reduced behavior is because you in fact
reduce the rewards level ah so you're
saying because team you're reducing your
reduce you're not just adding
perturbations you're actually reducing
the overall also first get swamped
they're getting the Avenue pad is
reduced and nice 185 yeah which is what
you're doing with I mean what you were
talking about the website is the more
people do that the lesser or
yeah so that would make sense of this
kind of us to target so related to the
rebound idea that you had then you get
paid back their bonus contribute it's a
sense of frustration because amount of
the war that you would get keeps
reducing as you please and quality you
guys forgot to charge him for very
strong yes because your average payment
Peters tour as you can dip anything when
you average people to please expect
you're both thus reduces given that it's
a vendetta coastline so at the end your
bones as your pain remains the same so
so if I'm a local and I started out at
sixty percent accurate and then once the
only person after let's say get I I
don't think that the bonus that I get is
larger than the bonus I will get from
seventy to eighty percent yeah but
you're paying on those in theaters your
own son please as well your Portuguese
but your salary yeah it's unlikely you
are back right use up with 90k per year
plus bonus if you're doing really well
in your first few years you get the big
bonus your salary remains small as you
proceed your salary starts getting
really high your bones might get
comparatively lower yeah but the total
remain the same right so that's my
measurements that's changing the reward
structure from fixed plus bonus to a
larger fixed and a smaller bonus how
does it attract motivation I have so
they because the bones in that case it
will use some certainty as well as
opposed to a certainty of the the it
produces participation because it is
such a special
the bonus really suspect no no LOL fix
game is participating because many
people don't want to rely on bones is to
get paid they prefer the certainty of
the fixed price the guaranteed payment
because I say now you know what here's
your payment get twenty cents plus it
detected if you continue you might have
a bonus payment of technicians and if
you compare the two some people will
continue try to get the bonus that you
promised them but if you promise 50
Cent's immediately typically you capture
a higher percentage of the market this
is something worth trying the people are
in general also veracity so we didn't
try to take my out if we be at a given
people a minute easily other so it's
just saying it's a bonus you could say
if you continue working at your current
level for the next 20 tasks you could
make X more for the duct work you've
already done these remind you the
following Saturday the people did
Philippe our teachers that they gave the
bonus in the beginning of the year that
here is extra ten thousand dollars for
the year if your students at the end of
the year heat this amount and we're
going to take the bones off later
instead of saying here is your here at
the end of the year we're going to give
you ten thousand dollars if your
students perform well you say here's the
bones now take it but if you your
students don't hit we're good to call
from your cell in that that actually
made a tremendous improvement in the
teachers at work on so random function
system the evidence is solid as restless
um are you ever avoid losing people to
potentially would I what Trajan through
the quality of the work if that was
being worthless it in the comparison of
the two we don't use whether I'm afraid
that I might lose maybe I don't but when
I did the side by side just sewing the
score vs introducing the statements the
patrons work better so these folks who
are working more slowly in system to do
you have any sense of their subjective
satisfaction with what they're doing I
mean I've been labeled for no doubt born
extremely quickly it doesn't mean that
I'd be happy doing it I'm an idea Polly
so but it's just many people are
actually in that in that state maybe you
should be pushing them off something
that that's more difficult into some
engage makes use of the fact that they
want to be engaged in that way pointing
that paint it even figured out so they
think about a symbol and deeper more
yeah it's something I have em hears
about the reticle model you have a very
rich set of sort of empirical studies
what we'll do and then trying to analyze
that you can take two very different
points of view about the human subject
one is people are rational maximizers
and if you give them information they'll
use it if you notice on side and how do
you account for what they do based on
their maximization the others people are
not rational optimizers they're rats and
they have these quirks of risk versus
gain and this is a one system to and you
can manipulate that to get them to
maximize your idea actually not to their
benefit which of those could you pull a
budget initially the key in the keeping
of I wouldn't quite satisfied myself was
this part why do people convert to start
doing good work when they start getting
these treatments and if you take the
argument for people irrational then this
shouldn't be affected by such you know
subconscious treatment right so you
cannot say oh you know what I'm playing
with your nervous system limbic system
and so on and that I affect your
rational self and you're optimizing it
just the theory doesn't
click so I and it will some fat and then
being recorded but yes play a little bit
more their apps okay all right oh thank
you thank you
you